bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat premier numéro d' allant plus loin
je suis ravi de vous retrouver nous
sommes ensemble pendant deux heures deux
heures en direct avec vous on va prendre
le temps d'analyser de questionner toute
l'actualité politique parlementaire mais
aussi international vous allez le voir
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour ce nouveau numéro
de votre émission les matins du sénat où
vous allez être plongés au coeur des
travaux de la haute assemblée
[Musique]
m
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
manger c'est voter vous l'avez compris
nous sommes sur la côte normande à re
manche à l'emplacement même où les
alliés débarquaient en 1944 pour sauver
le monde libre de la barbarie nazie
justement nous allons rencontrer des
hommes et des femmes qui dans une forme
de résistance continue à se battre pour
préserver un mode d'agriculture des
traditions à savoir faire alimentaire
qui nous permettent de nous protéger de
la malbouffe
habitants de rouen de la seine maritime
et au delà donc cette catastrophe
résulte de l' incendie qui a pour
origine deux sites industriels les
entreprises lubrizol et normandie
logistique
je devrai tout d'abord redire combien
nous comprenons l'émotion et
l'inquiétude l'inquiétude que vivent
tous les habitants touchés par cette
catastrophe
et bien sûr il est de notre devoir d'y
répondre
le premier ministre devant la
représentation nationale a pris
l'engagement d'une transparence absolue
et je voudrais redire 1 que notre rôle
n'est pas de rassurer coûte que coûte
mais de dire la vérité
toutes les informations toutes les
données scientifiques sont et seront
donc rendu public au fur et à mesure que
nous en disposerons et cette audition
participe aussi de cette volonté de
transparence
je voudrais souligner la très grande
mobilisation du gouvernement et de
l'ensemble des services de l'état pour
faire face à cette crise et être aux
côtés des rouennais je pense au
ministère de l'intérieur en charge de la
gestion de crise de la santé s'agissant
des impacts sanitaires de l'agriculture
pour les impacts sur les productions
agricoles de l'éducation nationale pour
les écoles du travail
s'agissant de la protection des
travailleurs en particulier ceux qui
interviennent sur les sites et bien sûr
un ministère sur de telles installations
le ministère de la transition écologique
et solidaire et plus particulièrement
chargé de la prévention des risques
industriels et en cas d'accident de
prévenir tout risque de sur accident de
contrôler la réalisation par
l'exploitant des opérations de
dépollution et de superviser
l'évaluation à court moyen et long terme
de l'impact environnemental le ministère
rempli ses missions en s'appuyant sur
les expertises des agences de l'état
spécialisés je pense notamment à
l'ineris et allande cesse et en
s'assurant et je pense que c'est
important de le redire que des
industriels assume toutes les
responsabilités qui sont les leurs
l'ensemble dû gouvernement et donc
mobiliser autour de l'engagement de
transparence que nous avons pris une
attention particulière est portée
la recherche de dioxine dans les
retombées mais aussi dans les
productions agricoles
je voudrais souligner que ce sont des
polluants très long à analyser j'entends
dire mais pourquoi on n'a pas les
résultats sur les dioxines ce parce que
les analyses sur les dioxines prennent
du temps
donc ce qui explique que les premiers
résultats ne soient connus que depuis la
fin de la semaine dernière les premiers
résultats dont nous disposons
aujourd'hui sont inférieures aux seuils
existants pour les produits agricoles
nous avons besoin de plusieurs campagnes
pour pouvoir se prononcer dans la mesure
où les dioxines peuvent s'accumuler dans
les animaux et dans les végétaux donc la
surveillance se poursuit en lien étroit
avec lens s donc je voudrais souligner
que les analyses ont été réalisées le
plus précocement possible pour éclairer
les impacts environnementaux et
sanitaires de cet accident
par exemple lors de précédents incidents
de 2013
les services de secours ne disposait pas
du tout de d'outils de mesure comme ils
ont pu en mobiliser immédiatement
pendant l' incendie et c'est vraiment la
première fois que nous réalisons sur un
tel incendie des ânesses des analyses
aussi rapide sur un spectre aussi large
ces prélèvements continuerons aussi
longtemps que nécessaire
je pense qu'il ya un point qui inquiète
beaucoup les populations et les
rouennais ce sont les odeurs qui perdure
toujours sur place
nous avons conscience de la gêne et de
l'inquiétude qu'elles peuvent générer
les services de l'état ont fixé dès le
départ deux priorités claires à
l'exploitant des d'extinction du
sinistre mettre en sécurité le site pour
éviter un suraccident ans et puis
traiter les sources d'odeur cela passe
par le nettoyage des résidus de
combustion sur le site et l'évacuation
2000 fut dont 160 pouvant être à
l'origine d'émanations depuis hier un
espace de confinement est en train
d'être installées sur les fûts il
permettra leur manipulation leur
neutralisation et leur évacuation
tout en limitant les risques de
mauvaises odeurs en parallèle nous avons
demandé aux exploitants des deux sites
d' accélérer le nettoyage des résidus de
combustion combustion et le pompage des
eaux d'extinction qui peuvent également
être source de mauvaises odeurs
principal l'opération devrait être
finalisée avant la fin de la semaine
nous procéderons pour la phase
post-accidentelle qui vient de débuter
avec le même niveau d'exigence et de
transparence l'objectif de cette phase
est clair de procéder à l'évaluation la
plus précise des conséquences dans la
durée sur l'environnement et sur la
santé de cette catastrophe
pour cela les services avance avec un
proto protocole très clair cela passe
d'abord par le fait d' affiner les
substances susceptibles d'avoir été
émises dans l'environnement
donc nous avons ciblé dans la phase de
crise les principaux polluants nous
recherchons dès à présent les polluants
pouvant avoir des effets potentiels à
moyen et long terme donc comme nous nous
nous y étions engagés des substances qui
étaient stockés sur les sites ont été
rendus publics
alors je dois reconnaître que les listes
fournies par les exploitants ne sont pas
effectivement facilement exploitables
mais nous en a nous les avons également
transmis à l'ineris et allande cesse
pour qu'il nous aide à identifier les
éventuels polluants complémentaires qui
pourraient être formés lors de la
combustion de ces substances et qu'il
serait pertinent de rechercher dans le
cadre de la surveillance de
l'environnement
les premiers retours partiel dont nous
disposons montrent la pertinence des
substances recherchées dans les premiers
prélèvements et préconise l'analyse de
quelques paramètres complémentaires dans
les denrées alimentaires notamment des
phtalates et du zinc
il n'y a pas de demande de
préconisations de recherche de produits
complémentaires notamment dans l'air ces
données nous permettront d'alimenter la
surveillance approfondie de l'ensemble
des impacts environnementaux dans l'eau
dans l'air dans les sols dans les
produits agricoles
donc c'est une surveillance qui était
prescrite à l'exploitant lubrizol et
bien sûr les résultats des analyses qui
ont d'ores et déjà été faites seront
versés à cette surveillance
enfin cette cartographie de la pollution
de l'environnement permettra la
réalisation d'une étude de risque
sanitaire demandée par les autorités
sanitaires donc le gouvernement a
indiqué qu'il était favorable à la mise
en place d'un suivi épidémiologique
de long terme qui est engagée par les
autorités sanitaires locales
nous portons également une attention
très forte au transfert de contaminants
vers la chaîne alimentaire
c'est pourquoi depuis le début donc les
préfets le ministère de l'agriculture
ont pris des mesures de précaution très
rapide en édictant des mesures de
confinement sur les productions
agricoles dans la tente du résultat des
analyses notamment de dioxine que
j'évoquais précédemment
donc moi je suis bien consciente et le
ministre de l'agriculture également que
c'est une épreuve difficile pour les
éleveurs pour les agriculteurs qui sont
confrontés à la consignation de leur
production mais je sais qu'ils sont
aussi les premiers attaché à la qualité
sanitaire de leurs produits est
clairement l'engagement est bien de les
accompagner sur les pertes
d'exploitation qui peuvent être générées
et nous installerons vendredi avec agnès
buzyn et didier guillaume un comité de
suivi pour assurer dans la durée la
totale transparence sur les conséquences
environnementales et sanitaires de cet
accident rassemblera les collectivités
les associations de protection de
l'environnement les professionnels de
santé les représentants des riverains et
les professionnels impactés nous sommes
déterminés à faire la pleine lumière sur
les conséquences de ce grave accident
dans la durée au delà des conséquences
directement perceptible il faudra aussi
assurer la pleine transparence sur les
causes de cet accident
dès jeudi 26 j'ai annoncé la langue le
lancement d'une enquête administrative
qui complétera l' enquête pénale en
cours
aujourd'hui de nombreuses zones d'ombré
demeurent à commencer par l'origine même
de l' incendie alors que le site faisait
l'objet d'une surveillance rigoureuse
par le service des instants de pardon
les des services de la spa
l'inspection des installations classées
de la dréal depuis le précédent talent
accident survenu entre entre en 2013
pardon ce sont trente neuf inspections
qui ont été réalisés sur ce site
les dernières datant de juin et de
septembre un plan de prévention des
risques technologiques a été approuvée
en 2014
nous ne disposerons d'une analyse plus
précise des causes que d'ici quelques
semaines
mais d'ores et déjà j'ai saisi
l'ensemble des préfets afin qu'ils
demandent aux exploitants des sites
seveso de renforcer leur vigilance et
d'interroger leurs propres systèmes et
procédures de gestion des risques au
regard de cet incendie
vous pouvez le constater le gouvernement
et les services de l'état sont depuis
les premières heures pleinement
mobilisés pour protéger les français
nous l'avons fait nous continuerons à le
faire en pleine transparence y compris
sur les causes c'est ce que nous devons
aux français et à la représentation
nationale bien je vous remercie ma
famille je fais de la parole à mes
collègues qui ont souhaité s'exprimer
donc monsieur chaize
merci monsieur le président madame un
ministre trois questions relativement
simple vous avez évoqué effectivement 39
x 39 contrôler leurs deux dernières
années dans cette entreprise
la question qu'on peut se poser est ce
que trop de contrôles tulle contrôle
dans le sens où la difficulté à
expliquer comment un incident de cette
ampleur a pu arriver de façon plus
globale
est ce que votre gouvernement envisage
aujourd'hui une évolution des normes
seveso
suite à cette catastrophe
concernant les indemnisations donc le
fonds d'indemnisation des agriculteurs a
estimé on que des pertes agricoles
s'élève à 400 mille euros par jour
depuis le premier jour de l'accident
au total 1364 exploitations ont été
frappés de restriction est ce que
pouvait nous garantir que le principe de
pollueur-payeur s'appliquera
intégralement sur cette catastrophe et
que lubrizol indemnisera les
agriculteurs et prendra à sa charge tous
les coûts annexes tels que les frais
d'analysé ou le nettoyage
des écoles vous avez évoqué à un
ministre l'entreprise dans mon dit
logistique qui stockaient apparemment
plus de 4000 tonnes de produits lubrizol
sans être accréditée seveso comment se
fait-il qu'une entreprise mitoyenne d'un
site seveso seuil haut ne soient pas
contrôlés ou en tout cas surveiller et
donc plus globalement comment expliquer
l'existence de telles lacunes dans un
processus de contrôle de sites
industriels
merci monsieur chaize mama ministre ce
cher est revenu sur un point sur lequel
j'avais pas moi même entendu votre
réponse à savoir comment se fait-il que
l'usiné normandie logistique n'est pas
semble-t-il satisfait à son obligation
de 2,2 rôle de parent d'accréditation au
titre du régime d'enregistrement
d'autorisation et se soit contenté d'une
simple déclaration sans que les services
de l'état apparemment sont soit ému
donc les 39 contrôles n'ont
manifestement pas permis d'empêcher cet
incendie cet incendie
à ce stade je pense qu'on ne peut pas se
l'expliquer puisque nous sommes dans un
entrepôt qui a un dispositif ce qu'on
appelle de sprinklage c'est à dire que
dès qu'il ya un échauffement dans
l'entrepôt des quantités très
importantes d'eau doivent tomber sur
l'origine de l'échauffement et
manifestement ce défunt ce dispositif
est dimensionnée pour permettre
d'éteindre un incendie
donc aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
d'explication sur pourquoi ce dispositif
n'a pas permis de prévenir les incendies
c'est vraiment le rôle de l' enquête
judiciaire et de l'enquète
administrative de nous éclairer sur ce
qui a pu se passer
et du coup quand vous posez la question
de l'évolution des normes seveso
je pense que à une catastrophe de cette
ampleur doit forcément nous amener à
réinterroger les normes les procédures
c'est ce qui se fait systématiquement
c'est comme ça que suite à la
catastrophe d'azf ont été mis en place
des plans de prévention des risques
technologiques
on aura certainement des enseignements à
tirer d'une telle catastrophe mais je
suis pas en mesure de vous dire
aujourd'hui ce qui pourra être décidée
tant qu'on n'a pas une analyse des
causes de l'incendié donc vous avez
entendu des deux industriels qui seront
voit un peu la balle sur l'origine de
l'incendié mois à ce stade je n'ai aucun
élément et donc je pense qu'il faut
qu'on soit très prudent et évidemment il
faudra quand on aura des
éclaircissements sur les causes de cet
incendie qui n'aurait pas dû avoir lieu
dans l'entrepôt
en tout cas qu'ils étaient supposés être
équipées de dispositifs empêchant un tel
incendie il faudra qu'on en tire toutes
les conséquences
je veux vous confirmer qu'effectivement
on est dans l'application du principe
pollueur payeur donc
l'exploitant a à sa charge les
opérations de dépollution de nettoyage
doit évidemment prendre également à sa
charge les analyses
il doit même réaliser un suivi
environnemental dans la durée et donc il
nous doit
un plan de surveillance que nous devons
valider il aurait dû nous remettre ce
plan le délai c'était vendredi dernier à
ce stade
le préfet a dû lui écrire pour lui dire
que le plan ne nous semble pas
satisfaisant mais donc il doit produire
ce plan
ce plan sera évidemment à sa charge et
de la même façon l'industriel aura à
indemniser les préjudices notamment ceux
subis par les agriculteurs
moi j'ai vu le président international
de lubrizol et j'ai eu l'occasion de lui
dire que je trouve que l'entreprise n'a
pas été à la hauteur dans la gestion de
cette catastrophe en particulier sur le
temps qui a été nécessaire pour nous
fournir des listes des listes dont je
partage tout à fait le fait qu'elles ne
sont pas parfaitement lisibles ou en
tout cas pédagogique
mais néanmoins on n'a pas voulu
perdre de temps et on a souhaité les
rendre publiques
lorsqu'on les a eus pour c'est en effet
des références internes de l'entreprise
avec des références à des fiches de
sécurité qui au moins permettent d'avoir
toute la transparence sur les produits
qui ont été impliqués dans l' incendie
et peut-être par rapport à la question
vous posez monsieur présent quel je n'ai
pas répondu
c'est bien parce que ça peut être
compliqué comme l'a souligné agnès buzyn
de savoir quels sont les polluants
potentiel produit dans ce kit d'un
incendie que nous avons saisi l'ineris
landes 16 pour leur demander s'il était
nécessaire d'élargir les années les
prélèvements et des analyses à la
recherche d'autres substances et donc
j'ai mentionné la réponse qui nous a été
apportée donc a priori validant les
prélèvements qui avaient été faits
notamment dans l'air et sur les suit et
demandant de de détendre les recherches
sur les sur quelques produits
supplémentaires sur les produits
agricoles alors s'agissant des
situations normandie logistique
moi je vais être très prudente et je
pense que l' enquête administrative
devra là encore nous éclairer on est sur
un site qui a été construit dans les
années 50 c'est à dire antérieurement à
la réglementation à la législation sur
les installations classées pour la
protection de l'environnement
de fait les exploitants dans ce cas
bénéficient d'un régime d'antériorité
ensuite le site a évolué avec notamment
des agrandissements et dans le même
temps la législation icpe a elle aussi
évolué avec par exemple la mise en place
d'une pour certains entrepôts d'un
régime de d'enregistrement et
d'autorisation dans ce genre d'évolution
il ya d'une part ce principe
d'antériorité qui fait que l'exploitant
a le droit de poursuivre son
exploitation
mais il ya aussi une obligation de
signaler une fois qu'on a un changement
de législation
l'exploitant a l'obligation de signaler
si du fait de l'évolution de la
législation
il se trouve dans un régime
différent de celui où l'administration
la considérait jusqu'à présent
c'est-à-dire icpe soumises à déclaration
voilà moi je vais rester extrêmement
prudente à ce stade est vraiment l'
enquête administrative devra nous
retracer si voilà si si si des
déclarations qui auraient dû être faites
n'ont pas été faites et peut-être nous
éclairer à l'avenir sur la façon de
s'assurer que ces déclarations soient
mieux fait
merci même le ministre monsieur bérit
débat
oui merci madame la ministre pour vos
réponses mais dans le prolongement des
de la question précédente concernant
l'usiné normandie logistique
elle a mis un certain temps à
communiquer quand même la liste des
produits puisque on vient de l'apprendre
e wilaya il ya peu de temps
et est-ce que vous avez des informations
compte tenu que vous avez la liste entre
les mains sur les risques de pollution
supplémentaire par rapport à ça
deuxièmement deuxième question sur les
autres sites seveso
vous avez souhaité que dans les mille
trois cent douze sites qui existent
vous exigez un auto contrôle renforcé de
ses sites
est ce que vous êtes sûr que cet
autocontrôle va suffire c'est à dire que
les exploitants vous donner la liste et
cetera ou est-ce que vous souhaitez
aller beaucoup plus loin
par rapport à cela madame la ministre
donc le site de normandie logistique
donc ça n'est pas un site classé seveso
et donc il n'a pas les mêmes obligations
que
les sites classés seveso par
construction donc ils nous ont fourni
des listes qui maintenant je peux
supposer qu'elle retrace bien les
produits qui étaient présents sur le
site
par contre ils n'ont pas été en mesure
de nous indiquer aujourd'hui qu'elles
étaient des produits qui avait brûlé
puisqu'à trois entrepôts un qui a été
totalement détruit et deux qui ont été
partiellement détruits pour autant on a
du coup rendu publique la liste de
l'ensemble des produits et on a demandé
à l'ineris d'actualiser les
recommandations qui peuvent nous faire
sur la base des produits présents sur le
site de normandie logistique
alors on peut dire que les produits en
question se sont notamment de la gomme
arabique des écorces enfin des produits
plutôt de cette nature qui sont ceux de
l'entreprise normandie logistique plus
pardon oui alors que de la gomme
arabique des produits tels que de la
magnésie de la bauxite ça c'est ceux qui
sont en propre à normandie logistique
des halles phase d asphalte qui sont
stockés pour le compte de total qui est
également à côté et les produits
lubrizol
ce sont des matières premières et des
produits des produits finis et lubrizol
nous indique avoir fait appel à
normandie logistique pour le stockage de
produits non dangereux nous allons là
aussi nous sommes en train d'analyser la
liste qui nous a été transmise je pense
qu'il fait je vais rester extrêmement
prudente
là aussi faudra qu'on vérifie que les
produits pouvaient bien se trouver sur
ce site
merci madame bonne foi oui merci madame
est ministre il était indiqué dans la
presse que le vendredi 4 octobre vous
étiez entretenu avec le pdg de lubrizol
et que vous aviez demandé à l'entreprise
qu'elle assume pleinement toutes ses
obligations légales et réglementaires
que ce soit en matière de transparence
de mise en sécurité du site de sa
dépollution ou encore du suivi des
conséquences à moyen long terme de cet
incendie en application du principe
pollueur payeur
en même temps le vendredi quand 4
octobre tribunal à nice
thil de roy ont saisi par l'association
respire a donné raison à la demande de
l'association en nommant un expert
spécialiste en chimie et produits
industriels pour procéder à un constat
des conséquences environnementales de l'
incendie
et ce alors même que l'état sur
intervention du préfet de seine-maritime
refusé toute expertise indépendante et
contradictoire alors que vous réclamez
affirmé à juste titre faire preuve de
transparence comment expliquer que
l'état se soit opposé à cette légitime
demande d' expertise indépendante
la transparence doit prévaloir et toute
la transparence comme l'application du
principe pollueur payeur sur cette
affaire mais également sur d'autres
affaires
à cet égard vous me permettrez is
illustrer mon propos par la pollution
des terrains de l'ancienne usine saft à
angoulême site exploité pendant
cinquante ans et qui n'a jamais fait
l'objet d'une quelconque dépollution
alors que 50 tonnes de tricot lo ré
tilène se trouvait en permanence sur ce
site
il en résulte des sols pollués aux
métaux lourds
une nappe phréatique de tout un quartier
résidentiel polluer lourdement l'ère des
maisons alentour polluée au
trichloréthylène et jusqu à la dioxine
on parle beaucoup du dioxine aaron un
précédent il semblerait qu'on en n'ait
pas trouvé en charente il y en a 10 le
dioxyde qu'on a retrouvé il ya quelques
semaines à hauteur de 50 fois la norme
sanitaires autorisés dans les oeufs des
poules que les riverains consommer
jusqu'au début de l'été dernier et là
encore ces riverains sinistrés dans
leurs biens immobiliers dans leur vie et
dans leur chair se voient refuser la
possibilité d'obtenir une étude
indépendante contradictoires et exhorte
exhaustive de leur situation et dans ce
dossier nommé ministre que je vous
invite à examiner avec une attention
toute particulière
l'action combinée de l'état et du
département de la charente propriétaire
des lieux abouti à un renversement des
responsabilités ou c'est le polluer qui
paie le premier ministre s'est engagé à
ce que tous soient rendues publiques
tout il doit en être ainsi à rouen et
ailleurs l'état envisage utile de
changer sa doctrine qui consiste
manifestement a refusé systématiquement
les demandes d' expertise judiciaire
indépendante et contrat dit
dans ce type de dossier cette position
en effet plus tenable et ne peut que
conduire à des interprétations qui
laissent évidemment croire que l'état
aurait quelque chose à cacher et
couvrirait le responsable de la
situation
j'en termine enfin et surtout le
principe du pollueur payeur doit
s'appliquer à rouen et ailleurs donc
l'état dispose des pouvoirs pour faire
respecter ce principe et donc quelles
mesures envisagées vous de prendre merci
le ministre oui merci monsieur le
président alors effectivement je vous
confirme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
que j'ai vu le président de lubrizol
pour lui demander d'assumer toutes ses
responsabilités et je dirais même au
delà c'est à dire de ne pas attendre les
décisions qui pourraient intervenir au
civil pour assumer l'indemnisation des
professions notamment les agriculteurs
qui ont subi un préjudice important et
donc l'entreprise lubrizol a indiqué
qu'ils étaient effectivement en train de
travailler en ce sens je pense que dans
le principe
enfin une fois avoir en tête que c'est
la surveillance de moyen et long terme
de l'environnement relève de la
responsabilité ou est à la charge de
l'exploitant du site qui a créé le
problème environnemental donc en
l'occurrence lubrizol donc pense que
notre responsabilité en tout cas c'est
de veiller à ce qu'ils mettent en place
cette surveillance environnementale
selon les meilleurs standards et c'est
ce à quoi nous allons nous employer
c'est pour ça que nous avons pour
l'instant si je peux dire retoqué la
copie qui nous a été proposé
est-ce qu'il faut qu'il y ait d'autres
expertises enfin voila moi je je je je
suis pleinement conscient que la parole
publique la parole des experts n'est pas
cru ce que la parole d'autres experts
sera cru je ne sais pas mais ici
voilà ça sent le tribunal administratif
a prescrit des expertises très bien
j'alerte juste sur le fait que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
ces analyses qui sont réalisés
évidemment par des bureaux d'études
compétents qui sont qu'ils ont été
revue par des notamment di neri ce qui
est la structure qui a sans doute la
meilleure expertise sur ces sujets bon
si personne ne fait confiance
c'est effectivement un petit peu dommage
mais je pense qu'on va devoir vivre avec
et si depuis plus d' expertise
permettent de rendre crédible ce qui ne
l'est pas sur la base d'une expertise
d'écouté dont acte
dont acte alors vous évoquez une
question qui est différente sur les
friches industrielles
c'est évidemment un enjeu très important
je pense que c'est quelque chose sur
lequel on est forcément amené à
réfléchir à fortiori quand on se dit
qu'on doit éviter l'artificialisation
des sols
donc notre capacité à mieux utiliser les
friches industrielles est évidemment un
enjeu très important
la règle aujourd'hui quand un industriel
quitte un site classée pour la
protection de l'environnement
c'est une obligation de mise en sécurité
du site
une obligation de dépollution pour un
usage industriel
et puis de s'assurer de l'absence
d'impact pour les riverains donc je
comprends qu'il ya des débats et des
contentieux sur le site que vous
mentionnez moi je sais pas précisément
le dossier en tête et voilà la règle
générale c'est dépollution pour un usage
industriel
on peut réfléchir aux évolutions qui
pourraient être apportées sur c'est sur
ces obligations ultérieurement
merci monsieur gontard oui merci
monsieur le président merci madame
madame la ministre
depuis depuis trois ans on note une
augmentation des accidents sur les sur
les sites classés et la part des sites
seveso et était de 15% 2016 pour passer
à 25% en 2018 de quoi se poser des
questions sur l'orientation de la
réglementation en 2018 avec la loi
évoque votre gouvernement à retirer à
l'autorité environnementale l'évaluation
systématique des modifications de sites
au sein d'un même établissement pour les
confier au préfet en juin 2018
vous mais dit fier par décret la
nomenclature des sites installations
classées réduisant encore le périmètre
de la deux
de l'évaluation environnementale en
juillet 2019 avec la loi énergie climat
vous étendez l'évaluation au cas par cas
confiant toujours davantage de
compétences au préfet au détriment de
l'autorité environnementale
l'établissement lubrizol de ronds à
bénéficier de ces assouplissements un
monsieur le président l'a rappelé
l'exploitant a présenté deux demandes
successives d'augmentation des quantités
de substances dangereuses stocker et
dans les deux cas le préfet a considéré
qu'il n'avait pas lieu à une environ une
évaluation environnementale
toujours dans la même logique le
gouvernement persiste en annonçant un
élargissement du régime d'enregistrement
pour les entrepôts allant jusqu'à 39
cents mille mètres cubes avec bien sûr
la fin des études d'impact des études de
danger pour ses installations le 23
septembre trois jours avant l'accident
de lubrizol edouard philippe annoncé
également un grand chantier de
simplification pour accélérer les
projets industriels et parmi les
propositions autorisé le démarrage du
parti des travaux bien sûr sans entendre
l'autorisation environnementale
donc ma question est simple est-ce que
ce terrible événement at-il fait prendre
conscience au gouvernement que les
intérêts industriels ne sont pas
compatibles avec la sauvegarde des
populations et de l'environnement
et est ce que vous allez en tirer les
conséquences et revenir sur une
réglementation qui on le voit et est
devenu trop laxistes et puis pour finir
j'en profite pour vous inviter le 29 le
no 29 novembre un colloque que nous
organisons ici même sur la démocratie
environnementale et sur l'ensemble de
ces questions
merci merci je suis contente de rappeler
ma question sur laquelle j'ai pas eu de
répondre effectivement sur
l'augmentation du stockage de produits
dangereux qui aurait été décidé au début
de l'année 2019
madame la ministre alors sur
l'augmentation des accidents vous
mentionner monsieur le sénateur j'ai pas
ces informations donc je pense qu'on va
pouvoir
creuser le sujet ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que les sanctions que
l'administration a eu l'occasion de
porter auprès des exploitants à ont
augmenté donc ça montre que les
inspecteurs sont présents sur les sites
et que la vigilance est importante quand
tu es manquements sont constatés
de mémoire on doit être à 400 de l'ordre
de 400 sanctions en 2018 ont des tas de
plus un peu plus de 300 en 2016
donc je pense qu'on ne peut pas dire
qu'il n'ya pas une présence importante
des inspecteurs sur les sites et je
pense que les chiffres que je viens de
vous citer sur les sanctions qui ont été
prononcées montre que par ailleurs la
vigilance est importante sur ces sites
et s'agissant en particulier du site de
lubrizol je rappelle 39,39 contrôle
depuis 2013 ensuite vous mentionnez des
mesures de simplification qui ont été
adoptées peut-être je pense qu'on sera
partagé une réflexion avec vous c'est
que nous nous inspecteurs constatent que
le temps qu'ils passent aujourd'hui sur
les dossiers est beaucoup plus important
qu'auparavant
et évidemment le temps qui passe sur les
dossiers il ne le passent pas à
contrôler les sites donc que se dire que
ça traduit le fait que les dossiers sont
plus riches et plus compliquée qu
auparavant mais en tout cas mais en tout
cas quand on réfléchit simplification
administrative c'est aussi l'idée de se
dire ce qu'on attend d'abord d'un
inspecteur d'installations classées
c'est qu'ils soient sur le site
évidemment c'est démarche de
simplification
elles ne doivent pas conduire à baisser
la garde
en termes de sécurité je voudrais
rappeler que la sécurité c'est pas
l'évaluation environnementale
c'est l'étude de danger et donc des
études
l'évaluation environnementale c'est ce
qui vient donner
l'évaluation de l'autorité
environnementale sur l'étude d'impact
d'étude d'impact sur l'environnement
donc on à l'étude de dangers l'étude
d'impact
l'évaluation environnementale dévalué
l'autorité environnementale sur cette
étude
donc je pense que ce qui est très
important s'agissant des sujets de
risques et je vais pas vous dire que je
me désintéresse de l'impact sur le
l'environnement mais en tout cas comme
on est en train de parler de risque
c'est que les études de dangers soient
faites et soit faite systématiquement je
pense que c'est fait je vous dis c'est
sans doute l'occasion de s'assurer
aujourd'hui dans cette remise à plat
suite à cette catastrophe que des
simplifications administratives moi je
peux pas être contre par principe des
simplifications administratives et je ne
serais certainement pas pour des
simplifications qui viendraient
effectivement réduire le les garanties
qu'on peut avoir sur la sécurité des
sites donc je pense que votre commission
denquête et la mission d'information de
l'assemblée et les enquêtes
administratives enquête administrative
que j'ai demandé permettront de vérifier
que cet esprit qui est de dire ce pas
parce qu'on passe plus de temps sur des
dossiers administratifs qu'on contrôle
mieux le risque ce qu'on est dans le bon
équilibre ou est ce qu'il ya lieu de
réfléchir à des ajustements s'agissant
précisément donc des arrêtés qui sont
intervenus sur le site il ya en effet eu
deux arrêtés qui sont intervenus le
premier qui mettait à jour des
prescriptions techniques sur une unité
qui n'a rien à voir avec l'endroit où
s'est produit l'incendié
donc c'était une modification qui devait
permettre une nouvelle gamme de produits
et n'augmente à sion de stockage met
donc dans un autre
notre partie du site et le second le
second arrêté visait à augmenter la
capacité de stockage possible sur le
site est en fête s'est arrêtée n'a pas
été mis en oeuvre
donc on va dire que ces deux arrêtés
n'ont pas de lien avec l'accident ou en
tout cas avec l'impact de cet incendie
moi je vous dis je pense que
ce qui me paraît essentiel au regard des
sujets de risques industriels dont on
est en train de parler c'est de
s'assurer que ne baisse pas la garde que
les études de danger soit couvre les
situation les évolutions qui sont
proposés par l'exploitant soit que des
études de dangers sont actualisés si ça
ne devait pas être le cas et je pense
que là encore toute la mise à plat qu'on
va être amené à faire dans le cadre de
l' enquête administrative de votre
mission de la mission d'information de
l'assemblée et votre commission d'
enquête permettra de vérifier que c'est
bien le cas
merci même le mm d'eau sidrac merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
en fait effectivement l'accident qui est
survenu à l'usiné lubrizol nous nous
inquiète tous bien évidemment on
souhaite avoir des explications
on a rappelé les chiffres du nombre de
sites seveso dont 705 qui sont donc
classées classé en seuil haut moi j'en
ai un dans ma commune qui est vous savez
le syndicat intercommunal qui est en
charge de la dépollution de toutes les
eaux de la région ile-de-france qui est
un grand site le siaap pour ne pas le
citer qui a connu un accident début 2018
un second plus récemment cet été en 2019
vous savez on a eu voilà on a eu
quelques inquiétudes des fumée noire qui
s'échappait de lusine avec tout de suite
bien évidemment une prise en charge par
le préfet on nous a dit que les fumées
noires ne contenait pas du chlorure
ferrique donc tout cela on nous n'avions
pas de raison d'en douter
ma question madame ministre au regard de
tout cela au regard de ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui aaron pensez vous
pensez vous que nous avons véritablement
une chaîne de contrôle et des
dispositifs en fait de contrôler un 2
sur tous ses sites seveso on en à 1323
le président l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
répartie tous ne sont pas évidemment
tous ne sont pas en seuil haut
mais pensez vous qu en fait notre chaîne
de prévention pour prévenir ce type
d'accident fonctionne bien existe bien
et efficiente puisque c'est vrai qu'il
est important de traiter les sujets
lorsqu'ils surviennent c'est c'est
normal vous nous avez je pense d'une
certaine manière donner des explications
toutefois en termes de prévention avant
nous aujourd'hui des dispositifs
suffisant merci monsieur le président
moi je je les dis hein je partage à la
fois et je comprends l'émotion et
l'inquiétude des habitants de rouen et
de l'ensemble des papes et acteurs
économiques ou des habitants qui ont été
impactés par incendie je voudrais quand
même partagé avec vous que l'incendié a
été maîtrisé sans sur accident et que
hausse au vu de des analyses dont on
dispose sur l'air sur l'eau sur les sols
et les premiers résultats sur les
végétaux
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de résultats
anormaux
c'est évidemment très choquant d'avoir
un panache de fumée du type de celui
qu'on a eu dans le cas de cet incendie
mais il ya certainement des enjeux de
particules par ailleurs donc voilà
clairement mauvais pour l'environnement
ça j'ai pas de doute mais en tout cas je
pense qu'il faut quand même faire le
constat que
sous réserve des analyses qui sont
encore en cours sur les productions
agricoles
il n'y a pas eu à ce stade de détection
de polluants anormal suite à cet
incendie
je pense que on a une des législations
pour ne pas dire la législation la plus
la plus protectrice d'europe puisque non
seulement nous appliquons évidemment la
directive seveso dans sa dernière
révision mais par ailleurs suite à
l'accident d'azf des dispositions on va
dire spécifiquement française ont été
mises en place avec les plans de
prévention des risques technologiques
qui ont pour objet de réduire le premier
point d'entrée c'est de réduire le
risque à la source et de demander aux
industriels de faire le maximum pour
réduire les risques à la source et une
fois ces risques réduits
au maximum ensuite il ya des mesures qui
sont prises pour la protection des
riverains et des activités à proximité
du site qui peuvent aller sur de
l'expropriation qui peuvent aller sur
année sur d un droit de délaissement qui
peuvent aussi aller sur la mise en
oeuvre de mesures de protection
ça c'est sûr le cadre on va dire
législatif et réglementaire
donc moi je constate qu'aujourd'hui ces
plans de prévention des risques
technologiques
il se réalise
la plupart même je crois 90% non sens
sont réalisés ils se mettent en oeuvre
lentement donc je pense qu'il faudra
qu'on s'interroge sur le rythme de mise
en oeuvre des mesures qui sont prévus
dans le cadre de ces plans notamment des
travaux qui se réalise à petite vitesse
peut-être parce que parce que parce que
c'est toujours gênant de faire des
travaux chez soi et même s'ils sont pris
en charge
peut-être que tout le monde n'a pas
forcément une culture du risque qui fait
qu'on se bousculeraient pour aller faire
ses travaux en tout cas je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui doit nous
interroger et ensuite sur les sites
seveso
on a des fréquence minimale de contrôle
je pense que c'est des contrôles manuels
sur les sites seveso
donc voilà je pense que les sites sont
inspectés régulièrement ensuite voilà
peut-être que dans le cadre de la mise à
plat que nous sommes amenés à faire
suite à cette catastrophe on pourrait
être amené à regarder s'il ya lieu de
renforcer encore des des aspects ce que
je peux vous dire par exemple c'est que
je trouve qu'il n'est pas normal qu'on
met autant de temps par exemple avoir
une liste de produits et du coup ça fait
partie des points sur lequel j'ai
demandé au préfet de prendre la tâche
des exploitants pour qu'on s'assure
qu'on peut disposer d'une liste de
produits compréhensible donc voilà parmi
les pistes sur lesquelles on doit
travailler sur aussi
peut-être on aura à réfléchir sur ce que
j'évoquais au départ s'agissant de
normandie logistique
ces sites qui existait antérieurement au
la législation sur les installations
classées qui peuvent changer de
catégorie en fonction des évolutions de
la législation et de la réglementation
voilà je pense que c'est une zone qu'il
faudra sans doute regarder de façon été
[Musique]
merci madame la ministre madame préville
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
donc il ya plus de 40 ans on a
connaissez la catastrophe industrielle
de seveso avec une pollution à la
dioxine qui a provoqué un réel
électrochoc et pourquoi cet électrochoc
bon il y avait eu un incendie qui a été
éteint comme tous les incendies
s'éteignent et heureusement qu'on a deux
les sapeurs pompiers qui ont pu à rouen
devrait pour que cela n'entraîne pas un
sur accident mais le gros problème ce
n'était pas ça c'était l'absence de plan
d'urgence
c'était ça le problème est là le manque
sur la protection des populations or sur
cet accident de rouen quel est le
bénéfice en fait du classement seveso
est ce que ça a apporté quelque chose de
plus sur la protection des populations
parce que finalement l'incendié a été
éteint maîtrisé certes mais finalement
les témoignages disent que certains
n'ont pas entendu de sirène que des
enseignants sont sont allés dans leur
établissement scolaire que des élèves
sont arrivés
or en la matière ce qui est très
important c'est le confinement
c'est à dire de ne pas sortir du tout
quand il ya ce genre de pollution quand
ya ces suies et tous et toutes ces
molécules qui sont dans l'atmosphère
c'était ça à la base orlins sand il est
en pleine nuit et à des gens qui qui se
promènent à 8 heures du matin dans le
périmètre a impacté
c'est ça qui pose problème la protection
des populations elle n'a pas été là c
est je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on
s'interroge là dessus je m'interroge
aussi sur la liste des des des produits
qui était contenu des molécules
enfin c'est quand même simple
l'industriel c'est très bien ce que ce
que donne la combustion des produits
qu'ils stockent c'est de la chimie tout
simple donc y est
peut donner est normalement fin après il
faudrait voir comment comment on voit
dans dans l'encadrement qu'on pourrait
donner en supplément sur ces sites
seveso de prévoir effectivement d'avoir
la liste mais directement on doit
l'avoir directement des produits qui
vont s'échapper sa problem après sur le
périmètre des 500 m je me pose la
question sur la pertinence puisque le
comme vous avez dit le panache il est
allé très loin il était il était très
large
donc peut-être que la protection est
elle suffisante et puis dernière chose
sur la quantité et la quantité des
produits qui étaient stockés qui
provoque évidemment ce risque énorme
parce que pour l'instant on n'a pas
détecté la dioxine parce que comme vous
l'avez dit à faire du temps mais quand
même souvenez vous qu'à seveso ce que ça
a donné la décontamination six pages du
strass et c'est enlever la terre sur une
certaine épaisseur s'est tout dé tout
démonter et stockées mais je dis pas
qu'il ya sahara où je ne dis pas mais si
c'était sa dépollution quand même très
important mais la ministre
[Musique]
je pense que le classement seveso
il a remporté un certain nombre de
conséquences
d'abord que les études de dangers prêts
permettent de connaître les polluants
qui sont à rechercher
de fait les polluants alors je vais
peut-être faire un retour en arrière je
pense que cette législation
elle est issue de la catastrophe de
seveso que vous avez mentionné
elle a été complétée en france suite à
la catastrophe d'azf dont je voudrais
rappeler que c'était 31 morts je crois
que c'était plus de 2000 blessés
ça a été 26 mille logements endommagés
voilà et donc je pense que l'esprit de
ces législations sont calés sur le
risque immédiat et en particulier les
études de danger met en évidence les
polluants qui peuvent présenter un
risque immédiat pour la santé
je pense que c'est quelque chose auquel
il faut sans doute qu'on réfléchisse de
travail et non pas seulement sur les
polluants qui présentent un risque
immédiat
par exemple le h2s le jeune l'hydrogène
sulfuré voilà
celui qui sont en mauvais celui qui est
dangereux pour la santé là c'est celui
qui est toxique
celui qui est immédiatement toxiques bon
donc voilà cette législation elle est
certainement fait pour prendre en compte
les risques immédiats pour
l'environnement et pour la santé
elle ne va peut-être pas assez loin ou
en tout cas elle ne traite pas sans
doute aussi bien les questions de
risques de moyen et de long terme donc
d'où les questions que nous avons posées
à l'ineris et allante cesse notamment
dans le perspective du plan de suivi à
moyen long terme des conséquences
potentielles sur l'environnement et la
santé et donc les mesures qui sont enfin
des indications qui nous ont été donnés
notamment sur l'ineris soit fait que la
liste des produits que nous avions
recherché était bien conforme à ce qu'on
peut imaginer
produit par un incendie sur le site le
fait d'être classée en seveso fait aussi
qu'il ya des moyens d'extinction
important alors moi je vous ai dit je
pense que personne ne peut se satisfaire
du fait que malgré les moyens
d'extinction sur le site et notamment
les dispositifs de sprinklage il faudra
qu'on comprenne pourquoi ça n'a pas
suffi à prévenir un incendie mais en
tout cas ses moyens étaient présents sur
le site
et puis de fait compte tenu du
classement du site
il ya à la fois un pays où heath qui est
un plan d'opération interne de
l'exploitant qui doit savoir qu'est ce
qu'il doit faire
en cas d'incident d'accidents et il y a
le plan particulier d'intervention qui
est déclenché par le préfet et qui
prévoit la mobilisation des moyens donc
je pense que
je suis certaine que ces éléments ont
pré permis de contenir l'incendié
je voudrais rappeler que ces 15% du site
qui a été détruit 15 % donc avec
effectivement des risques de sur
accident qui ont été évitées donc sans
doute tout n'est pas parfait mais je
pense quand même que cette législation a
été tout à fait utile dans le cas
présent merci monsieur mon délit oui
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je vais pas évoqué ni les circonstances
ni conséquence puisque je pense que les
différentes procédures en cours
permettront de faire la lumière sur
l'efficience qui s'est produit et puis
les conséquences pour l'environnement et
les populations
moi je vous réfère simplement un constat
et j'ai ensuite une question constat
c'est que ce qui s'est passé traduit à
la fois l'absence totale de culture du
risque et de zfs est le corollaire c'est
qu' aucune action de prévention
globalement sûr sûr sûr les populations
en direction des populations
et puis deuxième point deuxième constat
c'est la défiance totale
par rapport à la parole publique on a
vécu depuis longtemps en tant qu'élu
local mais aussi en tant que
parlementaire et et vous donc en tant
que ministre et donc c'est un vrai souci
aujourd'hui en crédible de nouveau la
parole publique et je pense que dans ce
cadre là alors sur sûr c'est sur cet
événement précis je pense qu'une seule
voix aurait été sans doute mais c'est
facile de dire après la solution plutôt
que dispersé les interventions mais j'ai
pas de il n'y a pas de de règles en la
matière mais je pense que la parole de
l'état aurait pu être incarnée par
parasol une seul interlocuteur
l'interlocutrice en l'occurrence pour ce
qui concerne la question vous avez
évoqué les plans de prévention des
risques technologiques seveso la mise en
oeuvre qui qui tarde sur un plan de
mesures en cas de cv pertes et moi je
voudrais ma question porte sur le sur
les plans communaux de sauvegarde et sur
les dix crimes est ce qu'à ce stade vous
avez un état des lieux précis sur le
nombre de communes qui nous et qui sont
engagés dans ces plans communaux de
sauvegarde dans les différentes
procédures qui sont possibles est
obligatoire
logiquement pour les communes merci
monsieur madame le ministre
alors on sort un peu du champ de
responsabilité de mon ministère
en tout cas moi je peux que partager
avec vous le fait que fajr à différents
enseignements plus sur la partie gestion
de crise
attirés en lien avec le ministre de
l'intérieur je pense notamment que on
peut constater que l'information
n'arrive pas aux citoyens
[Musique]
effectivement on a pu avoir ces alarmes
asseyez sirène qui ont été activés
j'espère que les citoyens ont bien
repéré que c'était la sirène qui
prévient qu'un risque industriel se
manifeste en fait on a un gros sujet je
pense de voir comment on peut toucher
rapidement les citoyens touchés
rapidement y compris moi j'ai été
surprise pour tout vous dire de voir à
la télé une pharmacienne qui disait ce
n'est pas du tout ce qui s'est passé
la grèce était présente pourquoi la
chaîne ne redescend pas plus vite pour
que tous les professionnels de santé et
les analyses qui avait été mise en ligne
le vendredi je pense qu'on a vraiment à
regarder ces sujets qui sont au-delà du
champ de mon ministère mais je pense
qu'avec la ministre de la santé on peut
aussi regarder ces sujets et puis la
culture du risque quand j'évoquais le
fait que les pprt
leur mise en oeuvre doit nous interroger
ça veut dire que bien qu'il y ait dans
le cadre notamment des sites seveso
une étude de danger une étude d'impact
soumises à enquête publique
donc ça veut dire qu a priori les
populations ont une connaissance dans l'
enquête publique qu'il y avait un site
avec des enjeux en termes de risques
industriels particulier il ya des des
commissions de suivi des sites les
anciennes clique qui s'appelle
maintenant les c2s qui doivent aussi a
priori permettre d'associer les
riverains afin de les informer
régulièrement des dispositions qui sont
prises sur les sites comme vous dites
ensuite il y a une information qui est
donnée par l'état sur les dix crimes et
qui doit donner lieu à des plans
communaux de sauvegarde
alors là pour le coup on sort totalement
de on change donc je ne suis pas en
mesure mais je ne doute pas que mon
collègue ministre de l'intérieur pourra
vous informer sur la réalisation de ces
plans communaux de sauvegarde
voilà donc je je je pense qu'il n'y a
pas de doute sur le fait qu' on a
progressé sur cette culture de risque
enfin on le voit aussi bien dans les
risques naturels
quand on voit des gens qui partent par
tempête en pleine mer alors que des
alertes ont été donnés c'est à peu près
le même sujet malheureusement ça peut
avoir des conséquences aussi dramatiques
ensuite sur la crédibilité de la parole
publique moi je crains qu'on vive avec
pendant très longtemps donc peut-être il
faut aussi réfléchir à la façon d'avoir
des expertises indépendantes demandé
alors pas non plus en faire 36 mhz et
donc du coup de réfléchir à la façon
dont on peut peut-être plus vite mettre
en place des comités du type de celui
qu'on installera avec didier guillaume
et agnès buzyn vendredi qui pourraient y
compris prescrire des études ou des
analyses vont bien je vais donner la
parole à monsieur pascal martin avait
peut-être rencontrer sur le terrain
puisqu'il a la chance d'être ça n'a pas
duré longtemps un cumulard puisqu'un de
rejoint au jour encore trois jours donc
c'est un moment donné il doit profiter
ils viennent rejoindre le sénat ya
quelques jours il préside encore le
conseil départemental de seine maritime
oui même la ministre très rapidement
pour vous dire que
comme vous j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller
sur site et dès le premier jour puisque
vous l'avez rappelé l' incendie se
déclare à 3 heures du matin et moi je me
suis rendu sur place à a1 aux heures du
matin puisque le panache commencé à
passer au dessus de l'hôtel du
département
une première question c'est la question
de l'urbanisme
ce sont les villes qui se sont
construites autour de ces entreprises
alors ces entreprises sont venues
s'installer en seine-maritime profitant
de l' axe seine qui naturellement et est
un axe privilégié pour pour
l'implantation de ces entreprises
ça c'est la première chose est ce que on
sera amené à repenser ces questions
d'urbanisme lorsqu'on sait qu'à quelques
centaines de mètres à vol d'oiseau de
lubrizol est aujourd'hui en train de se
construire un éco quartier qui portera
le nom de l'éco quartier flaubert est
toute la question est posée de savoir
est ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
raisonnable de pouvoir autoriser à
quelques centaines de mètres de ces
entreprises qui participent au
développement économique de la métropole
de rouen normandie et du département de
la seine-maritime je suis pas du tout en
train de de dire qu'il faudrait
installer ces entreprises à la campagne
pour caricaturer mon propos mais la
question de des autorisations
d'urbanisme est posée me semble d'une
façon accrue par par cet accident majeur
deuxièmement je rejoins cette question
de de la culture du risque
actionner les sirènes à 4 heures du
matin ça n'aurait parlé à personne je
veux pas être le porte parole de l'ap
des populations mais manifestement cette
culture du risque n'est pas partagée lé
petit à petit partager avec les
scolaires dans les écoles primaires dans
les collèges peut-être dans les lycées
mais ce n'est pas suffisant troisième
élément on sait très bien que la
réglementation en matière de lutte
contre
les incendies s'est construite après des
drames des dramatiques événements celui
de seveso
le rappel 1976 en italie moi je pense
qu'il faudrait aussi imaginer de
renforcer la politique non pas de
prévention mais de prévision et la
différence est notable
la prévision consiste à partir du
principe que on ne peut pas imaginer le
risque nul et qu'il faut imaginer des
moyens adaptés pour faire face à ces
incendies on sait très bien que plus un
incendie et maîtriser rapidement moins
il a de risques c'est une lapalissade de
d'aller au delà du périmètre propres de
l'établissement et causé des dégâts
comme on a connu et moi je pense qu'il
faudrait imaginer un renforcement des
équipes en interne de sécurité il en
existe je lubrizol
mais je pense que au delà des moyens
d'extinction comme le sprinklage mais
des moyens humains
je pense qu'il faudrait renforcer les
moyens humains avec du matériel et puis
peut-être aussi renforcée elle existe
mais peut-être qu'elle n'est pas
suffisant de la coopération entre les
différentes entre les différents
établissements qui sont implantés sur
sur la métropole rouen normandie parce
qu'on sait que il y à des coopérations
mutualisation et de solidarité pour
notamment apporter de les mills heures
pour éteindre ces incendies je pense
qu'il faudrait aussi réfléchir à
renforcer la coopération entre entre les
usines seveso situé sur un même site
voilà et puis dernière chose je pense
qu'on ne fera jamais assez en terme
d'information des populations
donc on ne pourra pas s'exonérer à
l'issue de cette dramatique incendie de
reprendre je pense à 0
l'information des populations voilà
madame ministre
merci même ministre comment ces
informations ne peut plus sérieuse alors
je pense qu'il faut en effet qu'on
reprenne ce sujet et qu'on trouve des
moyens plus efficaces pour prévenir les
populations ce qui suppose certainement
mais là c'est un petit peu aussi le
sujet des plans communaux de sauvegarde
que chacun soit bien informée en amont
des risques et de ce qu'il est amené à
faire si le risque se matérialise sur
les sujets d'urbanisme
vous savez que les plans de prévention
des risques technologiques ont justement
instaurer des périmètres dans lesquels
les habitations voir tout autre
installation est interdit dans lequel
des ens des activités économiques
dès lors qu' il ya des mesures de
gestion coordonnée peuvent être
maintenus et puis des périmètres au delà
dans lequel on a un droit de
délaissement
est ce qu'il faut aller au delà je ne
sais pas je note quand même il me semble
que dans l'élaboration de ces pprt s'est
déjà souvent considéré comme très
contraignant par les collectivités
j'ai quelques expériences de préfète en
tête
ou quand on essayait de l'est c'était
des discussions quand même un peu
compliqué donc je pense que les
collectivités peuvent ne pas être
toujours enthousiasmé à l'idée que le
pprt est un périmètre étendu
donc je crois que ça dépérissent et
c'est pareil voilà donc en tout cas est
alors dans le cas présent fin je pense
qu'il faut aussi qu'on est en tête à
queue finalement le panache de fumée
alors en l'état actuel on n'a pas faim
des analyses sont rassurants puisque
aucun polluant anormale n'a été
constatée dans les communes sous le
panache de fumée mais le panache il a
quand même eu des retombées jusqu'à
valenciennes
donc ça montre que si on en est sûr les
pollutions diffuses de moyen terme
ça pose la question à une autre échelle
voilà peut-être pour vous dire mais vous
l'avez vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le
sénateur que je pense que dans le cas
présent vraiment la mutualisation des
dispositifs d'intervention de l'ensemble
en fait un des sites d'eu seine maritime
a bien fonctionné et c'est effectivement
quelque chose qu'on
il encourage notamment pour les
industriels qui sont sur un même site ou
même plateforme on va dire merci
monsieur ou goethe
merci monsieur le président madame amis
je vais m'exprimer en lien avec nelly
tocqueville qui est retenue donc en
seine maritime pour des raisons de santé
je reprendrai un peu les propos que
deuxièmement délit parce que deux points
en particulier le premier il faut quand
même reconnaître que la communication
gouvernementale concernant l' incendie a
était incohérente et a sans doute
contribué à susciter des peurs ou du
moins les accentuer aujourd'hui je crois
que la crise n'est pas terminée
dans la mesure où les rouennais
l'ensemble des habitants du département
vivent toujours dans le doute et on
aurait peut-être gagné en temps et en
sérénité si cette communication avait
été à la fois concertée et coordonnée
alors je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous je crois que les rouennais demande
à ce qu'on leur dise la vérité est ce
qu'on les informe et pas uniquement à ce
qu'on puisse les rassurer mais néanmoins
donc des inquiétudes demeurent chez les
habitants notamment ceux qui sont
revenus chez eux qui s'interrogent à
l'heure actuelle sur un certain nombre
de dysfonctionnements qui ont marqué le
début de la crise et qui ont respiré
notamment dans la nuit donc les
substances qui ont été issus de la
combustion les demeures aussi pour les
enseignants et les agents qui ont
nettoyé des locaux scolaires alors qu'il
ne disposait d'aucune mesure attestant
de l'absence de danger 2 même inquiétude
chez les enseignants encore des parents
d'élèves qui au gré des odeurs et du
vent reçoivent des consignes de
confinement
nelly tocqueville nous disait par
exemple qu'elle a vécu le 3 octobre dans
sa commune qui est situé à 15 km à
l'ouest de rouen qui n'aurait donc pas
été touché par le nuage le 26 septembre
pourtant ce jour ce jour là cette zone a
eu à pâtir des retombées des odeurs et
des picotements à la gorge notamment
chez les habitants donc les inquiétudes
demeurent toujours notamment aussi pour
un cas particulier qui est celui des
gens du voyage qui occupe une ère qui
est situé à 400 mètres du site et qui
n'ont reçu aucune information et en ce
titre n'ont eu droit à aucune protection
et demeure même même intensité
d'inquiétude pour bien évidemment tous
les acteurs économiques les salariés les
commerçants et ainsi de suite
donc comment
redonner la question je vous pose c'est
comment redonner de la confiance à la
population comment unifier la
communication et puis ma deuxième
deuxième point rejoint également face à
une catastrophe on se rend compte que
que les populations sont désemparés ne
sachant pas quels bons comportements à
adopter on a d'ailleurs en discussion on
prenait l'exemple des des commissions la
colle locale d'information qui sont des
structures d'information qui fonctionne
donc il ya parliez des clis tout à
l'heure dans lequel on retrouve les élus
les syndicats disent les représentants
bien évidemment d'associations les
experts et aussi les exploitants et que
ces commissions locales d'information
sont compétentes en matière
d'information sur la santé sur la
sécurité des riverains etc
elle contribue à diffuser une culture de
sécurité malheureusement il n'y a en
france que 53 cli 38 sur les sites
nucléaires et peut ainsi commencer un
des sites non nucléaires n'ont peut-être
information à vérifier donc
comment là aussi développer ses outils
qui sont des outils de concertation et
diffusion d'une culture de sûreté sont
de nature aussi à rassurer les
populations en cas d'incident merci aux
chiottes
même le ministre peut-être sur le 2-2
dernier point que vous mentionnez sauf
erreur de ma part les commissions et
ancien crie désormais csc 2 s doivent
exister sur tous les sites seveso seuil
haut ce qui devrait faire 700 sites
donc on va vérifier que c'est bien le
cas mais normalement c'est
réglementairement prévu sur les sites
seveso seuil haut
vous posez la question de la gestion de
la crise le préfet en parlerait mieux
que moi et mon collègue ministre de
l'intérieur également
la proche que le préfet a mis en oeuvre
conformément au pays a été je le redis
un tréteau de faire des mesures sur la
pollution de l'air mesures qui n'ont pas
permis à ce moment là comme par la suite
de mettre en évidence des polluants dans
des concentrations anormales et donc
c'est ce qui l'a conduit à mettre en
place un périmètre de sécurité de 500
mètres
alors ensuite je ne sais pas s'il ya une
aire de gens du voyage officiel ou si
les gens de voyage était là sur des
terrains non prévus à cet effet mais
voilà normalement il y avait un
périmètre de protection de 500 m ensuite
mon jeu je comprends les inquiétudes un
mois je pense qu'on va pouvoir diffuser
les résultats de tous les prélèvements
et analyses qui ont été faits par
l'exploitant qui ont été faits par les
pompiers par atmo normandie qui ont été
faits par les services de l'état
et puis peut-être par des expertises
indépendantes en espérant que tout ça
finisse par convaincre les populations
sur les teneur en polluants qui sont
pour tout ce qu'on a pu mesurer jusqu'à
présent en dessous des seuils sur lequel
il y aurait une alerte et puis par
ailleurs enfin moi je le redis agnès
buzyn bien bien confirmé que une étude
épidémiologique de long terme seraient
mises en place et là aussi en espérant
que ça puisse rassurer les populations
concernées ou demeurant à je précise
qu'il n'y en avait eu une suite à
l'accident enfin tout cas l'incident de
2013 qui n'avait pas conduit à signaler
d voilà des pathologies ou en tout cas
des conséquences pour la santé
suite donc à ce suivi épidémiologique
qui a été fait postérieurement à aux
fuites qui est intervenu en 2013 mais ça
n'est pas nécessairement le même type de
produits qui ont pu être rejetés dans
l'atmosphère
monsieur bignon je reviens sur cette
histoire
concernant les agriculteurs je suis élu
de la somme donc là une zone qui est
riveraine et le nuage est passé au
dessus de chez moi clairement j'ai pas
mangé de frambois ce week-end près
principe de précaution alors il ya deux
choses des agriculteurs c'est évident
qu'il faut les indemniser le plus vite
possible c'est culturel et légumes le
lait c'est des gens qui gagnent pas
énormément d'argent ils sont fragiles et
donc c'est bien de dire on va les
indemniser j'ai noté les déclarations
vous avez fait à ouest france et à
d'autres médias c'est très intéressant
et très important mais il faut le faire
faut pas dire que s'il ya un moment
donné où il va on peut pas ne pas
ramasser les et dire aux gens vous
débrouillez vous comment vous allez
faire pour payer vos échéances à la la
coopérative paiera pas le chèque de les
manches et il faut pas oublier que le
laisser le salaire des notamment des
petits agriculteurs il ya certes dans la
somme une ferme de millevaches
mais toutes les fermes non pas
millevaches donc ça c'est un point qui
est vraiment important sur lequel du g16
cessé de la même chose pour nos voisins
et amis normands
d'un côté et de l'autre de la vallée de
la bresle c'est le bleu sujet est
exactement le même et on est on est tous
évidemment solidaire la deuxième chose
que je voulais aborder
c'est une interrogation sur la comment
dire le caractère jeu peut-être pas le
mot sincère et peut-être exagéré le le
problème delà du doute qui qui qui
habite un certain nombre d'élus locaux
et de et de producteurs locaux
on vous dit le nuage passe clairement au
dessus de la zone où j'habite sur une
sur une quarantaine de kilomètres à peu
près et woods il a par exemple on peut
pas on peut pas prendre le lait des
vaches mais là dans le village d'à côté
on peut prendre le lait des vaches là on
peut prendre les légumes
là on peux pas j'ai l'exemple d'un
cultivateur qui déclare au courrier
picard je l' ai pas rencontré
personnellement mais je pense qu'il a
dit la vérité
voilà je voulais faire un silo
d'ensilage à tel endroit et on m'a
interdit de le faire mais sur la terre
voisine qui est exactement à 300 mètres
de là où on voulait qu'ils fassent ou on
ne veut pas qu'ils fassent le le silo
d'ensilage on l'autorisent à ensiler
donc il ya une espèce d'incohérences
dans la crédibilité de la décision qui
est prise clairement quand le nuage
passe alors il ya des endroits où on
ramasse de la suit il y en a on en a pas
mais il ya plein d'endroits dans les
chiens en plein d'endroits dans les bois
plein d'endroits dans les jardins où
vous croyez qu'une dame qui a 75 ans va
aller voir ce dans son jardin si son
petit potager couvert de suie et si elle
peut le le déceler moi je serais
partisan d'avoir une vision un peu plus
globale
quand on voit le mitage il ya 39
communes qui auraient été concernés dans
la somme
je ne revendique pas que la mienne soit
indemnisée jeudi en termes de cohérence
géographique
ça paraît extraordinairement
invraisemblable mais là c'est cauet de
là vous avez été touchés là vous n'avez
pas été touchée ça se passait à 200 m
les territoires sont mitoyens
les cultivateurs soute cultiver même pas
une catastrophe naturelle sa choisit pas
l'endroit où ça tombe ça tombe par tous
et comment les servants c'est le sait le
le fameux la fameuse histoire de la de
tchernobyl le nuage de tchernobyl
s'était arrêté sur le rhin contrairement
à ce que certains ont cru un moment où
ce jeu contrairement à ce qu'on a dit un
autre
voilà j'ai fini mais je pense que ça
deviendrait une vulnérabilité
ça donnerait de la crédibilité si on
avait une vision un peu plus globale du
problème madame ministre que les yeux
bienveillants n'a pas mangé
peut-être vous indiquer que s'agissant
des framboises et autres productions
naturellement j'ai aussi saisi lohan f
l'agencé française de la biodiversité
les agences de l'eau pour qu'elles
participent aussi au suivi
environnemental de moyen et long terme
effectivement mais là je voudrais pas
empiéter sur les compétences de mon
collègue didier guillaume
en fait les communes enfin il
les préfets ont invité les forces de
l'ordre les collectivités les
agriculteurs à signaler les retombées de
celui qu'ils avaient pu constater dans
une commune et c'est sur c'est la base
de ces signalements que des communes ont
été classés dans celles dans lesquelles
les productions agricoles sont consignés
alors peut-être qu'on aurait pu avoir
une approche encore plus large
mais en considérant que toutes les
communes comprises entre rouen et
valenciennes dans tous les départements
affectés
voilà écoutez donc du coup le le voilà
les installations les exploitations qui
sont concernées sont celles dans des
communes dans lesquelles soit les
agriculteurs soient les élus soient les
forces de l'ordre ont signalé des
réponses retombées du panache de fumée
peut-être qu'on pourra réfléchir à
méthode plus plus scientifique ou
différentes pour pour les enfin voilà
comme comme retour d'expérience 8 à 7
cette catastrophe et j'ai bien noté la
préoccupation sur les agriculteurs je
peux vous assurer que didier guillaume
est totalement mobilisée pour qu'on
trouve rapidement une solution pour qu'
il y ait une prise en charge rapide par
du brise hall pour voilà tenir compte
des préjudices importante que subissent
les agrégats et si monsieur gold merci
monsieur le président mais là nos
ministres alors on arrive en fin de
série les questions finissent par être
redondantes
mais j'aimerais moi revenir sur le
phénomène de défiance du public par
rapport aux informations transmises
comme le rappelle un certain nombre de
nos collègues il ya quelques années déjà
jérôme bignon en parler un nuage c'est
théoriquement arrêté à la frontière et a
largement engendré méfiance et défiance
sur les catastrophes industrielles
force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui si
c'est l'entreprise qui informe elle est
partie prenante donc peu crédible si ce
sont les scientifiques on leur
reprochera d'être à la botte d'un lobby
si c'est le gouvernement il sera taxé de
vouloir étouffer les affaires et même si
l'info est la plus transparente on y
ajoutera la théorie du complot
le tout relayé bien sûr à grands coups
de réseaux sociaux alors la tente du
grand public allait par contre légitime
je m'interroge sur les procédures
actuelles qui accompagne toutes les
installations ici pe qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs seveso ou pas alors on a
parlé mais je pense qu'il faudrait
revoir les procédures et vous en parlait
dans vos propos madame la ministre pour
inculquer la culture du riz cela aussi
beaucoup ont évoqué pour que dès le
dossier de création
il est la plus grande transparence et
qui dépasse bien sûr le simple la simple
enquête publique parce que souvent c'est
limiter un peu à ça pour grand public et
qu'au cours d'exploitation il puisse y
avoir un point régulier obligatoire avec
une instance associant l'ensemble des
parties prenantes sur les activités
pouvant comporter un danger et ce avant
que le danger bien sûr soit réelle merci
aux seconds nommés ministres à moi je
partage votre constat sur la méfiance je
ne sais pas qu'est-ce convaincu
conséquence on peut en tirer
on aura forcément à y réfléchir ensuite
l'information régulière des populations
c'est logiquement le rôle des comités
des commissions de suivi de sites donc
les anciennes commissions locales
d'information
manifestement ça ne diffuse pas
suffisamment donc comment peut-on
élargir l'information des populations
delà de ceux qui participent à ces
commissions de suivi je pense que c'est
une question qu'il faut qu'on s'oppose
et puis je pense qu'il faut aussi qu'on
regarde comment les plans communaux de
sauvegarde se mettent en oeuvre parce
que là on est au plus près des citoyens
dans les informations que les mères
peuvent apporter
est-ce que ça se met bien en oeuvre les
informations circulent je crois que
c'est quelque chose qui mérite d'être
d'être regardée merci je vais donner la
parole à madame brûlés merci beaucoup
monsieur le président pour votre accueil
dans votre commission et pour cette
audition
madame la ministre à mon tour je vais
revenir brièvement sur les
assouplissements avec une question
simple mais aux lourdes conséquences
est il possible qu'à la faveur des
assouplissements que plusieurs ont
évoqué des entreprises dépassent les
seuils autorisés et en l'occurrence les
styles seveso
il est un certain nombre d'articles qui
ont l'air renseigner parce qu'on vous a
circulé effectivement beaucoup de choses
mais qui ont l'air très bien renseignés
qui laisse entendre que ce seuil aurait
pu dans au moins deux produits être
dépassée est ce que c'est le cas est ce
que c'est possible à lubrizol ou
ailleurs vous avez indiqué que vous
disposiez désormais de la liste des
produits qui sont stockés dans
l'entreprise voisine normandie
logistique quand je dis voisine
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas les
deux entreprises se jouxtent il ya une
clôture en gros qui les sépare le préfet
jusqu'à y ait encore quelques heures
indiqué des difficultés à obtenir cette
liste de produits donc vous semblez dire
que vous les avez et que la difficulté
c'est de savoir ce qui dans ces produits
a brûlé donc je voudrais des précisions
pour être sûr qu'on parle tous bien de
la même chose
je suis pas sûr d'avoir bien compris ce
que vous dites sur
le fait que cette entreprise normandie
logistique est antérieure à la
réglementation icpe mais c'est le cas
pour la quasi totalité des entreprises
lubrizol vous l'avez vous-même indiqué
date de 54 la législation n'était alors
pas celle qui en vigueur aujourd'hui
bien évidemment mais ça amène une
question c'est à dire que dans on a
évoqué les pprt une entreprise de
stockage aux côtés d'une entreprise
seveso il faut forcément qu'on sache ce
qu'il ya dedans et quels sont les effets
cocktail qui peuvent se produire avec
les produits qui sont contenus dans
l'entreprise elle-même seveso un petit
mot aussi certains l'ont évoquée pour
les agriculteurs avec ya plein de
questions mais je voudrais en pointe et
une c'est la collecte du lait parce
qu'au delà de la difficulté économique
du cref coeur que ça représente pour les
producteurs de lait de devoir jeter ce
qu'ils ont produit et dans les
difficultés financières quand on leur
connaît
il y avait des gens il ya des
engagements qui ont été pris par votre
collègue le ministre de l'agriculture
pour que les les
comme les les collecteurs de lait les
entreprises
les coopératives vienne collectés ça
n'est pas respectée c'est à dire que les
producteurs doivent stocker lors les le
jeter dans la fosse à purin pour être
clair et quand ça ne sera plus possible
ça sera jeter n'importe où ils pourront
et vous avez des propos rassurants et on
souhaite évidemment tout ce que l'on
s'en tienne là et que tous soient
rassurants mais si d'aventuré le lait
contenait d une pollution
il y aurait forcément un impact
environnemental au fait de ne pas le
collecter et de stocker de le détruire
dans les conditions les meilleures
2 dernière chose vous évoqué des pistes
sur les pprt et les travaux qui n'avance
pas suffisamment l'état visiblement
offre des crédits d'impôt pour les
travaux
il ya des endroits où les gens ne sont
pas en mesure d'avancer et à des
collectivités des communes par exemple
qui avance la dépense donc peut-être que
du côté de l'état il ya des choses à
regarder comme ça et puis puisque a été
évoqué le système d'information d'
alerte et y aura beaucoup de choses à
réfléchir
moi je voudrais dire et ça vous
surprendra pas que dans une assemblée de
sénateurs on vous alerte là dessus les
maires les maires sont des vecteurs
d'informations essentielles et
d'ailleurs il y en a beaucoup qui dans
leur commune ont mis en place des
systèmes d' alerte par sms ou par
d'autres dispositifs et c'est absolument
regrettable qu'il n'ait pas été saisie
par le préfet comme il aurait pu l'être
parce qu'ils auraient été des relais
d'informations extrêmement efficace me
semble-t-il
merci le ministre vous évoquez beaucoup
de sujets alors sur la collecte de lait
et la non collecte et la destruction du
lait peut-être dire que
on va attendre la suite des analyses je
ne pense pas il y à un seuil en dessous
duquel on est pour les analyses dont on
dispose sur la dioxine dans les produits
alimentaires il n'y a pas vraiment de
norme de référence dans l'environnement
on peut supposer que si on est en
dessous du seuil alimentaires alors on
est aussi sur les impacts sur
l'environnement mais voilà c'est un des
choses qu'on a mesurée sans pour autant
ce qui nous a permis de constater qu'on
était dans les ordres de grandeur
habituel en tout cas qui avait pas une
différence d'ordre de grandeur entre le
prélèvement de référence du blanc comme
on dit et ce qu'on a pu constater dans
l'environnement
mais fin de toute façon je pense que
personne ne souhaite qu'on souhaite
amener à détruire du lait pendant une
durée importante pour autant je pense
qu'on est tous aussi conscient qu'il
faut se donner le temps d'avoir toutes
les analyses y compris avec le
métabolisme qui fait qu'on peut
contrôler qu'il n'y aura effectivement
pas de problème de dépassement des
seuils pour des produits alimentaires
s'agissant de l'information des maires
et du rôle qu'ils peuvent avoir en
relais vis-à-vis des preuves des
populations vraiment c'est le coeur des
plans communaux de sauvegarde de mettre
les maires au coeur de l'information des
citoyens sur les risques et c'est bien
le principe du document d'information
communal sur les risques majeurs qui
sont élaborés par les préfets pour que
le mais rassemble sur son territoire
l'ensemble des risques
là je vais pas empiéter sur les
compétences de mon collègue ministre de
l'intérieur mais je pense que c'était
sans doute intéressant de regarder
comment se mettre en oeuvre notamment in
fine et les plans communaux de
sauvegarde les 12 maires qui étaient
concernés par le panache de fumée ont
été prévenus par le préfet je pense
qu'on aura dans sept retours
d'expérience sur la gestion de crise
certainement des progrès qu'on pourra
identifier sur la façon dont ils ont été
prévenus associé à informer et puis sans
doute au delà des douze maires il
l'aurait été
intéressant que d'autres maires et en
particulier ceux qui n'étaient pas
concernés par le panache le sache
donc je pense qu'on aura certainement
attirer des retours d'expérience sur ce
sujet sur les travaux des pprt a priori
moi je n'ai pas connaissance que ce soit
un problème de financement qui
retarderait la mise en oeuvre en tout
cas on l'a pas remonter normalement le
l'existant des dispositifs d'avant ce
qu'ils sont en train en tout cas
dispositif sera en place à partir de
2020 pour s'assurer que ça n'est pas
effectivement l'incapacité à faire
l'avant ce qui pourrait freiner la
réalisation des mesures de protection
qui sont préconisées dans le cadre des
pprt
pour revenir à votre première question
le site lubrizol
il est seveso donc j'imagine que la
question que vous posez sur les
quantités par nature de produits qui
étaient sur le site concerne le site de
normandie logistique
moi je préfère vraiment compte tenu du
caractère un peu erratique des
informations qui nous ont été donnés
laisser le temps à lenquête
administratives et aux services de
remettre à plat les informations qui au
demeurant ont été mis en ligne
mise en ligne sur les produits ce
contenu sur ce site
il n'y a pas de contradiction entre ce
que j'ai dit ce que préfet a dit la
liste à défaut d'avoir la liste des
produits qui ont été concernés par l'
incendie
nous avons rendu publique la liste de
l'ensemble des produits stockés sur le
site
effectivement le préfet essayent
d'obtenir de l'exploitant des précisions
en fonction des entrepôts qui ont brûlé
pour savoir quelles étaient les produits
dans les andes dans l'entrepôt qui était
totalement détruits et dans les
entrepôts qui ont été partiellement
détruits de savoir quels sont les
produits qu'ils ont brûlés on imagine
même que l'on d'exploitants devrait être
en situation de nous donner ces
informations tout cas c'est ce qu'on
demande
voilà pour cette audition que vous avez
pu suivre sur notre antenne vous pouvez
retrouvez tous les articles de la
rédaction public sénat sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
on reviendra notamment sur
publicsenat.fr sur l'article de simon
barbarie etc ce titre lubrizol
l'entreprise n'a pas dé
la hauteur dans la gestion des
catastrophes c'est l'un des messages de
la ministre vous avez pu donc entendre
dans cette audition c'est la fin de
cette émission très bonne sur des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]